oh mein gott
[Applaus]
jeder reinkommt spieler kennt das gefühl
in einer frischen welt aufzutauchen
generiert dafür um von ihm entdeckt und
geformt zu werden
unendliches potenzial welches auf seine
realisierung war es doch was passiert
wenn ich mit meinem ganzen körper kommt
wie fühlt es sich an zu schwimmen
schweine und zombies mit eigenen händen
zu töten minen zu graben und strukturen
nach meinen vorstellungen zu erschaffen
wie lange würde es dauern bis ich mein
altes leben vergessen und mich in einer
neuen existenz ohne grenzen verlieren
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist
für dieses experiment brauchen wir erst
tief ab hier ist das gute stück aber
damit ich damit 24 stunden lang kabellos
in minecraft verschwinden kann muss ich
noch jede menge software installieren
eine 9 5 gigahertz route für 200 euro
kaufen damit mein netzwerk schnell genug
ist und eine bank mit kabelbindern fest
machen damit der akku nicht länger geht
und als gegengewicht zur brille
zweitens der green screen damit ich euch
in die fantastische welt mitnehmen kann
habe ich mal einen 6 mal 3 meter
greenstream gekauft aufgehangen und
ausgeleuchtet ja das ganze büro ausfüllt
drittens das aufnahme ist ab ich habe
meinen pc und zwei monitore sanft denen
sofa tisch aufs sofa vormaligen
greenscreen gestellt in der ecke steht
eine kamera die an den strom und an den
pc eingesteckt ist und permanent
überträgt damit er mich genauso im spiel
integriert wie ich mich beim spielen
fühle muss ich die mixed reality kamera
in minecraft genau mit meiner echten
kalibrieren und stundenlang mit
verschiedenen videosignalen
herumprobieren das essen für die 24
stunden habe ich karotten gebackene
kartoffeln 1234 apple und kekse
der haken ich darf nur das essen was ich
in minecraft finde finde ich nichts muss
ich hungern
er starb ich werde in minecraft
unzählige tage und nächte durch leben
und dabei mein zeitgefühl komplett
verlieren schlafen und aufwachen tue ich
natürlich in einem bett in virtual
reality minecraft okay das gesamte set
up läuft jetzt und binden den spannend
brille kommt drauf neu erstellen
gespannt auf die kleine garde web.de
bcf ich brenne einmal aus jux und
tollerei sagt man dass ich sage also
hier herunter oh mein gott
also man kriegt eher unnormal dass fall
gefühl so kenne das gefühl wenn man
runterfällt natur ein mulmiges gefühl
hat man kann ja sagen ab und boxte und
das ist das allergrößte
ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass es
wirklich anstrengend ist aktuell geht
mir noch gut und ich habe richtig bock
jetzt gerade 24 stunden hier irgendwas
galt auch die beine stellen kann mich
hochstapeln ich bin richtig wirklich
unterwegs
die hitze schon oh mein gott das wird in
diesen 24 stunden so definiert drin
hey da schon über kommt der denn her ich
muss mich irgendwie vermitteln oder dem
boden hält sich aus einer der gründe
warum sich so viele menschen zu
minecraft hingezogen fühlen ist das es
uns erlaubt unsere überlebensinstinkt
nachzugehen anders als im glatt
geschliffenen modernen echten leben
fühlt man sich hier der natur ausgesetzt
und jeder gesammelte holzblock jedes
hergestellte werkzeug und jeder gebaute
unterschlupf triggert uralte mechanismen
und schüttet dopamin aus man fühlt sich
hier wirklich als wenn man im dreckloch
und müsste hier den weg frei buddeln und
die da sind sowie nach denn genau da ist
man der natur besonders ausgesetzt und
die gefahren fühlen sich in villarreal
als kritik an das ist richtig heftig das
ist ja ich sehe nicht mein gott das ist
fix
ich hab ich ja noch drei sätzen
ich will jetzt nicht nein nachdem mit
mir stirbt auch all meine beute und die
reise beginnt nach zwei mühevollen
stunden von vorn mir tut alles weh des
unfalls vor anstatt die ganze zeit hier
und warten
doch nicht nur auf diese art und weise
macht mir das experiment körperlich zu
schaffen nachdem ich schon seit mehreren
stunden nicht mehr an meinen physischen
körper gedacht hat bringt die viele
bewegung in wie schwindel und übelkeit
mit sich ich fühle mich als wäre ich
sehr krank und muss mich ausruhen um
schlimmeres zu vermeiden
die augen sind geschlossen aber die
brille bleibt auf gott die sonne alles
blendet sie zuhauf freiheit
ok ich muss gar keinen sinn
ich sage was geiles drin haben wir so
nicht gegen ein kleines hexenhäuschen
oder das nicht so wäre hätte ich hier
auch dass nur ein bild der katze gajic
kann sich die platz wissen ja wie kannst
du das kannst du meinen herzlichen und
das hexenhaus bietet mir für eine nacht
schutz aber schon bald breche ich auf
eine vierstündige extrem anstrengen der
odyssee durch steppen wüsten urwälder
und vor allem ozeane
es fühlt sich unwirklich an mit meinem
echten körper so schnell so viel an zu
durchqueren auf dieser reise mit nur
einem ziel eine heimat wo ich das haus
meiner träume bauen kann ist doch okay
mir gefällt es mir also alter gut dass
man das sagen
das ist quasi eine große fläche endlich
mal auch schön saftig grün und ein
dorfbewohner den jetzt mal an wert hallo
ist da aber die haben viel kram dass wir
jetzt ausbeuten können dass das treffen
sich nämlich ganz schön gut und
kartoffeln ich nehme alles mit
ich hab mich mega hunger mit dieser
kraft habe ich letztendlich geworden
auch in brühl hat frage schalten moment
ich erstmal jetzt jetzt glücklich ich
suche man kurze konnte
wir sind gott oh mein gott hin dass nach
dem ok jetzt ist er einfach so gestorben
cool
das willkommen wie komisch an
das wird total komisch an dem spiel hier
eine karotte zu haben und auf meinen
geschmack kosten eine karotte zu spüren
zufrieden mit dem entdeckten land ruhe
ich mich mit meinem proviant von der
langen reise aus bis ich von meinen
neuen nachbarn besuch bekommen und
jawohl geld um mein gott was auf ins
gefecht
da lang hallo da langsamer in den kampf
oder doch okay das mit dem langen und
hier funktioniert nicht so gut haben
mama du nervst haye
mit letzter kraft baue ich mir bis spät
in die nacht ein zuhause buchstäblich
mit meinen bloßen händen
[Musik]
ich habe das haus fertig fast zumindest
die gema sieht ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig aus hier ist so eine
glaswand der glasfront arg ich mir passt
voll gut dann geht es da hier hoch dass
eine plattform wo ich mein bett hin
gebaut ob das bett sieht so riesig aus
man hat sich eben mails oder noch recht
bequem aus dass relativ geräumig hat
wirklich ewig gedauert bis ich das
gebäude hat ewig gedauert bis ich das
gefühl habe aber also ich finds ich
finds echt schick hier ein bisschen
geschlafen wie wird es sich anfühlt in
virtual reality zu schlafen und vor
allem wie werde es sich anfühlen in
virtual reality aufzuwachen was werden
wir vorgehen wenn das erste licht dass
mein auge erblickt die minecraft sonne
ist wunderschönen guten morgen so ich
glaube wir gehen jetzt erst mal ein
bisschen was von mir tut immer noch
alles weh aber ich würde sagen wir
suchen jetzt mal richtig schicke hülle
also ich habe mich lange davor gedrückt
jetzt in der villa zu gehen einfach weil
ich davor tatsächlich ein bisschen
respekt habe
da ist auch eine schlucht in die gleich
reingefallen hoch meint server team und
ich arbeiten übrigens aktuell immer noch
an einem riesigen rpg minecraft server
mit unfassbar schönen städten und
landschaften mit quests eigenen monstern
magie wenn ihr gut bauen könnt kreativ
seid oder entwickler seit und sehr guten
minecraft plugins programmiert bewerbt
euch gerne über den link in der video
beschreibung war dass er in diese gehöre
pata pata zara wo mein gott oh mein gott
wo zombies sind viel zu wenig leute
nehmen das nun ändern macht der ist ja
süß und auf wenn ich ins fadenkreuz
hilfe alter ist der gruselig redstone
das doch mal was
nach fünf anstrengenden stunden in der
mine und nach über 20 stunden in denen
ich in einem computerspiel festgesteckt
bin ja da es sind die ja oh mein gott
pudel ich erst mal ein bisschen ein
damit ich in sicherheit bin ob mittel
alles so wie es ist einfach so
anstrengend teilweise richtig fleißig
habe alle ordentlich sie auch nicht auch
zu leben ok wo ist dieses hauses habe
auch absolut kein orientierungssinn ich
will einfach nur wenn diese bude rein da
ist es nicht endlich mein rücken
ich brauche eine pause ich muss hier
raus alter halbe stunde geil
okay die diamanten kommen da rein
aussehen mache ich mir später einen
diamant spiel zeigte dass ich mir
obsidian holen kann und den äther gehen
kann das werde ich aber den führenden
stunde nicht mehr schaffen also wenn ihr
das sehen möchtet mal das video auf
meine zweite kanal aus wo ihr mich mit
diesen dingen im äther sterben seht
meine augen tun auch gar nicht weh
tatsächlich aber ein computer extrem die
arbeit hat mir einen ofen köpfigen
snackt und wisst ihr was es bedeutet ich
denke jetzt auch in mühlhofen griffe
juden gemütlich hoffen gruppen essen was
eine aussicht
was europa jetzt echt dreckig
mittlerweile ich habe richtig
kopfschmerzen
wir gehen jetzt mal an die frische luft
raus und dann nehme ich das ding ab und
ich glaube dann dann schlaf ich einfach
ihr werdet jetzt mal gespannt wann wir
ein gesicht aussieht und ich auch mein
gott über kratz der wind tut so gut ich
habe wolf gefunden alles zufall gut war
erstmal duschen geile grafik ich ganz
ehrlich meine augen hat nicht so viele
probleme lag aber auch daran weil ich
oft meinen den augen der pause gegeben
habe und die zugemacht hat aber mein
kopf und mir tut hier hinten auch alles
wie es ist echt machen der angenehme
abwechslung was also flüssig läuft jetzt
kann auch wenn man sich bewegt er hat
halt immer minimal nach gehängt so dass
darin günstig hat aber das ist das setzt
also kann ich leben jetzt ins gras
virtual reality ist mitunter der gipfel
der menschlichen errungenschaften mein
lieblingsbuch eine kurze geschichte der
menschheit gibt die gesamte entwicklung
unserer spezies wieder von primaten bis
hin zur künstlichen intelligenz ich
komme zwar selten dazu selbst zu lesen
aber bei blinkt ist dem sponsor des
heutigen video gibt es unzählige
hörbücher die man beim aufräumen sport
oder autofahren hören kann blinkt ist
ist bekannt für die revolutionäre
zusammenfassung von büchern bei denen du
die essenz eines buches in der circa 15
minuten anhören oder durch lesen kannst
mit der funktion hören den doppelter
geschwindigkeit sogar noch schneller
wenn euch die zusammenfassung gepackt
hat könnt ihr jetzt noch tiefer
eintauchen mit hörbüchern in voller
länge es gibt ratgeber zeitlose
klassiker und bestseller aus
produktivität psychologie wissenschaft
persönliche entwicklung und viele mehr
und das auf deutsch und auf englisch
jeden monat kommen ca 40 neue titel in
25 verschiedenen kategorien hinzu auf
link fsd.de / theorie könnte sieben tage
lang kostenlos zu viele bücher
verschlingen wie er möchte und das noch
bevor irgend ein abo abschließt meine
zuschauer erhalten exklusiv 20 prozent
rabatt auf das jahres-abo blinkt es
premium ganz oben in der video
beschreibung linke.de storari abonniert
gerne diesen kanal und dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten mal gedacht macht's
gut
[Musik]